If I'm in project mode, I might as well
clarify some things that are out there
that I really need to get off my chest
and it starts with this:
I respect you. I respect you. I respect you.
So many of you. So many of you have
different opinions than I do.
Disagree with me. Comment.
Leave your three cents, talk behind my back,
and I want you to know, so there is
NEVER any confusion
that I respect where you're coming from,
you come from a different place with different circumstances and different narratives.
And I will respect it till the end. I really will.
As long as your points of view are
coming from a place of positivity,
added value, debate
intellectual curiosity -
I will respect you to no end.
And even for the people that are adding their two cents
to the conversation of MY life...
Maybe I'll save my framework of not leaving two cents
on your life, but if I don't there you go.
Even for the people that have taken the time
to add their two cents on my life
out of a place of weakness and despair,
a need to get a short dose of happiness
and the spitting of their negativity on my framework
disguised as constructive criticism
or lack of kool-aid drinking.
I respect it. I understand it.
And I deploy unbelievable amounts
of gratitude for my parents
and my neighborhoods
and my homies
And my early grit and grind that
created the foundation of my life.
I respect it. Respect it. Respect it. Speak your truths.